you're loving this I am I cannot believe
how there's so many beautiful women and
you're saying no to every single one of
them
no one's replied to me yet is that
something I said was that something my
mom said I'm her mother of this gorgeous
little boy here he's my baby
I feel so weird that you're about to do
this because I don't know if my mom
knows how to firstly you think the women
what do you know about tinder so the
first time I downloaded tinder was a
couple months ago and the only way that
I could do it was with a little help
from my friends
soompi no mother I'm fairly confident I
could help me find his ideal girlfriend
he has a lot to offer like I didn't
think I'd be this nervous but I'm pretty
scared right now I'm gonna try my best
so ma'am welcome to the world of tinder
yeah there you go
there's my Facebook account you need to
choose six photos that you think
represent me and that this is my account
with my default Facebook photo no you've
had better days that's not nice one that
one yes that shows how you know fun you
wanna know why Oh what about me they're
giving the finger no I thought that but
this one I like because it shows you're
artistic it may come to next advantage
with animals in with him there you go
one with all your mates you need to let
them know that you have friends the next
thing is going to be the description it
might be about me as a person or what
I'm looking for I'm available I'm
available that's all your writing I once
hinder so I am available are available
hey I'm looking for a fun sexy outgoing
lady my mom doesn't believe in
punctuation how's that sound to you this
is totally up to you what are the ages I
should be looking for what do you think
is appropriate 19 might be a bit young
gender what do you think women
you know tomato we've had this talk mom
so we're willing to travel up to 70
Kay's I'm not that desperate and we're
on tinder okay done
let's get swiping if you like it you
click love if you don't you click cross
you're wanting me to choose for you yes
haha I knew you someone special yeah she
looks too sad just outdoors whose
shuttles relax it's got little water
she likes water she's riding a horse gay
4/20 look at that mean 4/20 means she
likes smoking weed also paid she's the
same name as the one before at the same
person oh this is her profile yes
definitely a Gemini she looks old enough
to be your mother
oops let me take them I'll go back okay
he's gone forever you've ruined my
chances are no she's showing her bottom
well she's cheeky I think we'd like that
wow this is fun mom's just going nope
nope nope nope I've only seen guys as
well hey I don't like it how they do all
these though Samira selfie it's
desperate we just saw a group of men and
their bio was if you've got boobs swipe
right
mm-hmm she was hot did you really like
that me okay we'll go boobs for Nick
you're gonna have to say yes to someone
long no hmm
it's like it was sister thing this girl
has a photo with her dad who looks like
he would not like me one day oh it's
Imagineer dad now is that your dad why
would you say that is that your dad just
a conversation starter
so you just sleep alike to someone
that's bad would it be the super line
which one the one that was naked Oh Jess
five what are you gonna say I'm at work
at the moment and my mum's visiting okay
what about that do you think is hot so
my mother has matched me with someone
and she is going to start a conversation
now so how would you open up
conversation on tinder high really high
when I have coffee she said this weekend
for sure she said for sure look you need
to grab their attention Tim that is a
game a game gotcha gotcha that is so
creepy if I walk up to a random girl and
it's go gotcha
she's gonna get a drink with me well I
thought oh I don't know whether she's
going to block I'll call the police on
me well you've got a date for me now I
do this weekend but I don't know how I'm
gonna explain it to her hey just so you
know it wasn't me it was my mom you're
gonna leave that out of it so next step
next step that's it you cried in my
profile you pretty much Creek the hell
out of women online
no one's replying to me oh oh I'm very
sorry you don't really talk to your
parents about what they expect from you
in terms of partner it showed how high
the bar is for me
right mum thank you for should say
attempting to get my dating life back on
track you know me better than anyone so
if that's what you think represents me
best then I guess that's the best
profile I can have all right mum you've
made my profile now it's time for me to
create you a tender profile nick is
single because he's awkward
well you're not that altered obviously
it's opened up with my son he's single
because he's awkward